[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
set nearly a thousand years before the
events in the elder scrolls iv oblivion
and the elder scrolls 5 skyrim the elder
scrolls online lets you take part in the
story set within the compelling history
and deep lore of the elder scrolls
franchise
designed to be played exactly the way
you want to play
you can start wherever you like
with no level restrictions and no
subscription required
this massive world is yours to explore
alone or with friends choose a favorite
location or storyline and jump in
from the capital cities of the three
alliances to the magical summerset isles
from the kojiti territory of elsewhere
tomorrow wind the home of the dark elves
from frozen skyrim in the north
to the endless swamps of black munch
adventure is everywhere
options for creating and personalizing
characters in the elder scrolls online
are almost without limit
with access to a multitude of adventures
all across the width and breadth of
tamriel
and the freedom to play wherever and
however you like
it's time to begin
your elder scrolls story
are you ready to forge your own legend
greetings everyone welcome to the show i
know you're all excited to see the
amazing things we have coming up this
year but before we get started i'd like
to take a minute and just talk about the
video you just saw it was a brief
description of some of the basic systems
of eso but the game itself is so much
more than that
and i really mean it eso is just as much
a virtual world as it is a game as over
20 million of you know it's part of your
lives
over the last two years we know that so
many of you found some temporary respite
from the world by spending time in
tamriel we're so proud and so humbled to
help even in this small way
everyone at zenimax online is
continually reminded that we make the
game
but you make it awesome
that's why i want to take a minute to
welcome you those of you who have been
with us from the beginning those of you
have joined us recently and the many new
players who are looking for a new
fantasy virtual world to call home
welcome to you all
those new to the game will quickly find
that eso's greatest strength is
providing so many different ways to live
your virtual life in tamriel
solo group co-op pvp crafting decorating
your home chatting with friends it's all
there
we've got a ton of new things to share
with you in today's show for starters
this year-long adventure will be a
return to our storytelling roots instead
of another daedric invasion story 2022
will feature a tale of political
intrigue and subterfuge unfolding in a
location you have never seen before in
an elder scrolls game
ever
and with that i'd like to turn it over
to my good friend pete hines who is on
set and ready to go
welcome everyone to the 2022 elder
scrolls online global reveal event today
you're getting an in-depth look at the
next year-long adventure in the elder
scrolls online and as matt mentioned the
team at cinemax online studios is
excited to share exclusive new details
about a part of the elder scrolls that's
never been explored before and stick
around for a special eso live after the
show where we'll go over the upcoming
chapter as well as new details
surrounding our first dlc in this year's
adventure with me once again is the one
and only rich lambert
hey rich hey pete welcome
thank you i'm really really excited to
be here and hello to everybody back home
congrats on 20 million players it's a
huge accomplishment
for the folks tuning in who may not know
a lot about elder scrolls online give us
a sense of what is elder scrolls online
eso is an elder scrolls game first and
foremost and it is a game about your
personal journey through the world
with one tamriel
we removed all the arbitrary level gates
that prevent you from exploring and you
can just pick a direction and go and do
whatever you want and there's a ton of
stuff you can spend your time doing it's
not just like go fight things or do
quests but it's really a breadth of
content it is there's so much to do in
other schools online and it ranges from
questing to pvp
housing crafting the justice system
there's also loads of group oriented
content in our dungeons and trials
we've also got a number of collection
based systems that players can
participate in so from treasure hunting
to antiquities
collecting lore books and it's just the
list goes on and on and on it's a
massive game it's an elder scrolls game
but it's online there's a ton of stuff
to do just like you would expect in an
elder scrolls game
and much like an elder scrolls game it
has an amazing community around it
that's built up around eso talk a little
bit about the folks that have really
made this game what it is they're really
what makes
the game special it's the community that
makes the world come alive they are
incredibly supportive
they just love sharing their love of
elder scrolls with other players
and are hands down the best community in
games
these folks are truly what make this
game special and you know if you want
help they're always there waiting to
help you out
but it's really up to you to decide
whether you want to play this game by
yourself or or spend time playing with
others absolutely this is an online game
so you're bound to run across other
players
but it's your choice if you want to
interact with them or not
and i highly recommend that you do so
because the social bonds that you
develop with those players can last a
lifetime
and if you want to play online but
by yourself but not by yourself you also
have companions which are npcs that you
can bring along with you and what does a
companion do for you a companion is your
personal adventuring buddy they're
always there for you and they can help
you out progress through the world so if
you need a little bit of help tanking
enemies you need some extra damage you
need some healing they're always going
to be there for you so last question for
me before we jump in because i know
you're all super excited to hear what's
new you shared some exciting news last
year for the spanish speaking community
and i wondered if you had any new
details to share with those folks about
what's coming we do
so back in october we announced that
spanish localization was coming to eso
in 2022
we're very excited to let everybody know
that it will be available with this
year's chapter in june and we're also
excited to let you all know that the
spanish forums for the elder scrolls
online are live today so if you want to
come join us on elderscrollsonline.com
we've got the spanish forums up and
running live and we look forward to
seeing our spanish community there
great stuff
but i know everybody's ready to get to
that new content so what do you got for
us
so i'd like to welcome everybody to high
isle the next chapter of the elder
scrolls online and the centerpiece of
this year's legacy of the bretton's
adventure
let's check out our new cinematic
trailer
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
me
so we just got our first look at the
elder scrolls online hi aisle rich give
us a little background on this year's
adventure this year's adventure is
called legacy of the bretons and our
focus is on exploring breton lore and
culture it's a story that's being told
over four major updates this year and as
matt said earlier we're kind of going
back to our roots in terms of
storytelling this is going to feel like
a classic elder scrolls game
the bretons are this traditional
medieval feudal society with knights
noble houses and of course all the
politics that surround that politics our
fans love politics rich
especially in the elder scrolls at least
so for those familiar with tamriel in
the second area or maybe not talk a
little bit about the three banners war
and where it's left tamriel sure so the
three banners war is currently raging
throughout tamriel and it has left the
land fractured with all the factions
vying for power over cereal and the
imperial city
and this year-long story is focused on a
dream to end that war it's gonna be an
adventure
it's always an adventure now high isle
is a spot that most fans are not going
to be familiar with it's it's a bit of
an unknown it is it is a location that's
never been explored before in an elder
scrolls game
high isle is one of the four islands in
the sisters archipelago which is an
island chain located far to the
southwest of daggerfall and northwest of
somerset and has only ever been
documented by a single map in red guard
and it's really really exciting for us
to be able to do something completely
different this year completely new and
we can't wait to share it with everybody
now we're focused on the bretons this
year tell us a little bit more about the
bretons and their culture what can we
expect to learn in in this year's
adventure when you go to high isle
you're are gonna see that this is the
epitome of breton culture this is feudal
medieval castles and tournament grounds
this is a resort destination for
tamriel's wealthy and as it's far
removed from the mainland it's a bit of
a safe haven and therefore a perfect
location for secret peace talks between
the alliance delegates
and these peace talks are being hosted
by the society of the steadfast which is
a new faction led by an extremely
wealthy noble in high all named baron
vaquero and of course
this is an elder scrolls story
so of course there are groups out there
who stand to profit and gain power due
to the war so any hint of peace talks
could quickly result in an opposition
and sabotage we know who's behind
preventing these peace talks
we do so there are whispers of a secret
society named the ascendant order
who threaten to ruin the peace talks
they're led by the ascendant lord
and i'm going to leave the rest up to
the players to figure out ooh
cliffhanger now it's been a while since
zoss had the opportunity to create and
add completely new elements to the elder
scrolls so this has to be exciting for
you it is
amazing it's fun to go back and
re-envision content but conceptualizing
an entire region from scratch is
daunting
so who better to talk about that than
our art director cj greb and he's going
to walk us through it
hi everyone as always it's very exciting
to be part of creating a brand new elder
school story this time it's the sisters
archipelago and it's especially exciting
to get to build a little-known and
never-before-explored corner of the
elder scrolls world
our concept team began finding
inspiration for the island's look from
the beautiful windswept shores of the
mediterranean we see stunning waterfalls
imposing cliffs and oceanside beaches
that one would find scattering the coast
of the mediterranean sea
the landscape highlights the natural
beauty of the island but their
civilization as well
our team knew how important such an
addition of the world could be to the
deep history and lore of the bretons and
how important that would be to so many
fans of elder scrolls
we leaned into the architectural and
cultural traditions from medieval and
feudal europe
knowing this could be blended into our
established britain designs from the
base game
the dense city streets of guanfallen bay
and the idyllic coastal palace of castle
nevir are prime examples of the imposing
breton structures and hidden underground
catacombs born from that work
players will also find medieval fanfare
and splendor on the tournament grounds
where nobility and commoner alike enjoy
festivities
the nobles treat high isle like a resort
and that's reflected in the way the
nobles dress
high isle elite always dress in their
finest projecting their status as not
only the leaders of the great family
houses but their barely hidden ambitions
to command the archipelago with total
power
all of this pomp and circumstance gave
us the opportunity to return to the
classic medieval armor and attire so
distinct of the bretton's style played
armor tabards and heraldry
the beauty of high isle shines like a
beacon to the rest of tamriel but it
can't all be sandy beaches and
sunflowers the dark side of high isle
success lies directly to the north
there across the water you'll find the
dense deadly jungle island of aminos
this area serves as a prison for
criminals and dissidents deemed unworthy
of high isle once inside there are no
guards no law and little chance of
escape
good luck
there's more than two locations that
players can look forward to as the
sisters archipelago is an island chain
players will get to explore throughout
the year
high isle is one part of the legacy of
the bretons what we call our year-long
adventure rich what else can folks
expect
we're going to start this year off in
march with the ascending tide dlc and
that adds two new dungeons and stories
from that dlc set the tone and provide
backstory for the events that kick off
in the high aisle chapter in june and of
course this is a year-long story so
we're going to continue it in quarter
three and quarter four later this year
and it doesn't matter how much you've
played eso in order to experience the
new content right right both new and
returning players can jump in at any
time that's the beauty of eso you don't
have to level up through years of older
content you don't have to play it in a
specific order you can just jump in and
play at your own pace
now let's hear from our community team
on how you can get started with high
isle today
hey everyone we're here to let you know
that starting right now you can
pre-purchase the elder scrolls online
high aisle for all platforms this new
chapter will launch on june 6 for pc mac
and stadia and june 21st on consoles and
just as a reminder eso is available on
xbox series xns and playstation 5 which
features 4k high fidelity and 60fps
performance modes if you already own the
game you can get this version as a free
upgrade as for high isle you can
pre-purchase by visiting
elderscrollsonline.com or one of many
online retailers
now when you pre-purchase the chapter
you'll immediately receive a matching
set of the pale frost elk mount and the
limited time pale frost fun pet though
keep in mind the pet is only available
if you pre-purchase now through april
4th
we have a few different ways to hop in
and start your adventure in eso and if
you're wondering which version is right
for you well we're here to break it down
if you're new to the game and want to
dive in right now the eso collection
high aisle is for you this collection
gets you instant access to everything
the base game has to offer along with
all five previous annual chapters you
can play in any order however you like
so you can begin your tamriel adventure
today and of course you'll have full
access to high isle once it launches in
june alternatively if you already own
the base game or any of the previous
chapters you'll want to grab the upgrade
version we also have collectors editions
available that are great for new and
existing players alike these editions
contain even more bonus items that will
be available when high aisle launches
like a brand new mount type and an epic
armor outfit style so what about new
merch
we've got that too if you want to get
your hands on some sweet high isle merch
we have brand new items available for
pre-purchase on the bethesda gear store
like this ascendant lord statue
new high aisle t-shirt
key art lithograph and more
we'll both be back right after today's
show to give you a first look at the
ascending tie dlc and update 33 show off
some additional eso merch and more so
stick around and we'll see you all soon
and now let's hear from loremaster
lehman he's got details on the story
you'll experience in high isle and some
of the characters you'll meet along the
way
hey gang
i am so psyched to be part of the team
bringing a brand new story and new
setting to the world of elder scrolls
exploring the legacy of the bretons
provided us with a great opportunity to
dig into the history the culture and the
geography of western tamriel
while the sisters archipelago has gone
unexplored until now
every aspect of its history and culture
has roots in the lore of tamriel and we
have had a blast taking the bretons out
to sea and building high isle into
something familiar but also profoundly
unique
to begin let's touch on who the bretons
are they're a fascinating race with a
really complex history that hasn't
really been touched on in previous elder
scrolls adventures the britons are a
hybrid race the descendants of both
humans and elves which gives them a
unique perspective on nirn's oldest feud
the conflict between men and myr
it's a lot more than just knights and
shining armor
one of the most distinctive parts of
breton culture is how it's organized
high isle is an openly feudal society
that has a lot in common with the
european style feudalism we see in the
mid to late middle ages
peasants and sailors labor at the bottom
while nobles engage in an endless dance
of palace intrigues political marriages
and shifting alliances at the top
in the throne rooms of high rock and the
sisters isles ruthlessness can be a
virtue so watch your back
it's not all sinister plotting and
knives in the dark though the high
romance of arthurian legend has a place
here too
many breton nobles are stuck navigating
core conspiracies sure
but others the shining knights of old
set out on grand quest for adventure and
glory
and there's plenty of glory to be found
in the wilds of high isle and aminos
you won't do it alone though
a few of our favorite eso characters
from high rock and elsewhere are
returning to lend a hand
jakarn professional thief and rack on
tour
and captain xaji the khajiit captain of
the perfect pounce will both help you
untangle the plots of the ascendant
order
the zealots of the ascendant order are
the chief antagonists here and the
sisters these well-armed fanatics want
to bring about a new utopia without
crowns or thrones
and they're willing to kill as many
people as necessary to make that happen
you'll definitely want to keep an eye
out for their leaders too the ascendant
lord and his chief lieutenant descendant
magus these mysterious rulers may have
influence that runs deep in the sisters
aisles
high isle is packed full of intrigue
adventure and exciting breton lore i
can't wait for you to visit the sisters
you're really going to dig it
we've discussed the upcoming story and
location for our high aisle but we have
a new game system coming with this
chapter as well and i've been waiting
this whole time to talk about it because
it features something i love it's a
collectible card game you're right and
we're calling this new system tales of
tribute it's a collectible card game
that is played entirely within eso this
is something i've always wanted to see
come to eso and i'm super excited we're
finally able to add it so how will tales
of tribute be integrated into the game
like am i playing it wherever i want is
it certain situations how does this work
you're generally going to be able to
play it anywhere
you'll find it in taverns throughout
tamriel you can also just go up to
somebody and challenge them directly or
you can find a match in the group ui
and in addition there is a story line
that you could advance by challenging
certain npcs throughout the world or you
can play against other players as it has
its own ranking system as well so
there's a single player kind of thing
and there's also a pvp with its own
ranking system oh this is getting better
and better now
how do i earn new cards new decks i
assume there's there's some of both how
do i go about doing that
yeah so once you complete the tutorial
you unlock the four starter decks and
that's what gets you into playing right
away
and then as you explore the world you
complete the quests
you will start to unlock and find new
patron decks that add to your your cards
you will also find unique individual
upgraded cards as well so there's lots
of exploration tacked on top of it so
you said the ccg was different than
other ones so which one is this like is
this a resource building game is this a
combat game what what am i going to be
doing so this is a resource building
game where you're both working towards
trying to
reach the victory point goal and you can
do that in a bunch of different ways you
can use the patrons themselves to curry
favor to help you advance through it so
it's all about strategy rather than
combat and essentially we're on a race
to get to a certain number of points
gather the most resources before our
opponent does right
what kind of rewards do i unlock in the
game like i assume i'm just not
unlocking cards and decks do i get to
unlock stuff in eso itself
absolutely there are tons of different
rewards
in this ranging from cosmetics to
furnishings to gold to crafting
materials including transmute stones
which is something players really really
want
so there's really something for everyone
here
and i really want to enforce
one big point when it comes to tales of
tribute and that is you're not going to
be at a disadvantage if you're playing
someone who's already unlocked all the
cards
all the upgrade cards because at the
start of the game you pick two decks to
put into play your opponent picks two
decks they're shuffled together and you
both play from that same common deck
so it's not only balance so that i can
play somebody who's been playing forever
unlocked but i also get maybe a chance
to try some cards or decks that that i
haven't unlocked yet absolutely yep
super cool so excited about this and i'm
sure we got a lot more to share on this
we do we just scratch the surface this
is a really big system so as we get
closer to pts we'll give a lot more
detail and have a big deep dive on this
so stay tuned we're really really
excited for it
now pardon my terrible pun but i hear
there's something else in the cards like
maybe a new adventuring buddy or two to
help on quests you are correct so we
have two new companions coming with high
isle
the community loved the companion system
we introduced in blackwood so the team
has been hard at work adding more and i
don't want to spoil the stories too too
much but i'll give a little bit of a
tease
to the two new ones so one is named
ember and she is a khajiit
and the other is a breton named isabel
ember grew up on the streets so she's a
little bit morally flexible if you will
she's clever she's a bit wild she has a
knack for magic
whereas isabel on the other hand is an
aspiring knight who leans towards the
honorable ideal she's not preachy
lecturing or stiff though she just
really wants to do right by players it
sounds amazing can't wait to have a new
adventuring buddy as we explore the next
chapter now before you go is there
anything else
yeah there's tons more info to share
with you all
i just want to thank the community
we wouldn't be able to do this without
them
and i also want to take a moment to
recognize the team back home you know
everybody at home working on eso
they're
amazingly talented and passionate at
what they do
and they get asked to solve impossible
problems on a regular basis it is such a
treat to be able to work with this
passionate group of people
and get to represent them so from both
matt and i thank you so much everybody
for all you do you're amazing
today we've discussed high isle's
interesting locations characters and
lore we touched on an upcoming card game
system two new companions and digital
rewards players can unlock when they
pre-purchase the game we also announced
that eso will be available with spanish
language support in june
before we go i'd like to share a few
reminders eso high isle is available to
pre-purchase now on all platforms
new players who pre-purchase the eso
collection high aisle will get instant
access to the base game and all previous
chapters so you can start your
adventures right away and stick with us
for our post show hosted by jess and
gina we'll talk more about the things
we've discussed here as well as the
first dlc and the legacy of the
bretton's adventure thank you for
joining us we'll see you in tamriel
[Music]
[Music]
you